Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Und ich bin auch ein ganz großer Fan von Chaos.
Das seh ich natürlich ganz genau so. Das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Aber ich glaube, dass viele Leute sich selber da gar nicht mehr kontrollieren, sondern in diesen Dingen drin sind. Um Gottes Willen meine Daten, die darf ich nicht bekannt geben. Und sich gar nicht mal diesen Worst Case überhaupt nur mal eine Minute ausmalen. Was wäre denn im schlimmsten Fall? Das Beispiel hat mich auch nicht so beeindruckt. Also dann wissen sie halt, dass ich gerade am Computer sitze. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja nicht so gering. Also meine Güte, wo ist das Problem für mich?
Nee, nee, da geht es nicht nur darum, dass du da am Computer sitzt. Dann geht es darum, die wissen, wer gerade was am Rechner macht und wer das ist. Also lässt sich quasi wieder welche Seiten besucht er gerade. Also klar, ein plastisches Beispiel wieder, wenn jemand bei Facebook Mitglied in der Gruppe Pornostars finde ich geil und bei Xing Mitglied in der Gruppe Geschäftsführer von großen Firmen ist, dann kann man da vielleicht schon Informationen rausziehen, die wieder interessant sind. Aber ist natürlich auch, wie du das sagst, natürlich so ein Worst-Case-Szenario, klar.
Genau, es soll hier eigentlich auch gar nicht darum gehen, dass wir jetzt so die Paranoia-Schiene fahren. Also ist klar, hier E-Mail in dem Moment, wo du eine Mail verschickst und sei deinen Mailserver noch so sicher. In dem Moment, wo das in einem Gmail-Konto oder sonst wo landet, ist die halt public. Also man muss sich jetzt gar nicht der Illusion hergeben, dass man jetzt irgendwie noch anonym sein kann so richtig. Und irgendwie jetzt der anonyme Mensch sich da noch irgendwie durchs Netz bewegen kann. Wie gesagt, es geht eben eher um das Bewusstsein. Was mache ich da, was gebe ich da ab? Und was kann da die Folge draus sein? Und hier dieses mit diesem, ist ja nicht illegal usw. Das ist halt auch immer so ein beliebtes Argument. Es ist jetzt vielleicht gerade nicht illegal. Und damals, als wir mal eine Volkszählung gemacht haben, war das auch überhaupt nicht illegal. Aber zum Beispiel Jude zu sein, irgendwann ändert sich ein Gesetz. Und dann kann man halt auf so ein Datenwerk zugreifen und mal rausfinden, wer denn jetzt gerade plötzlich auf einmal illegal ist.
Nein, das Daten auch illegal genutze ich bin ja nicht naiv.
Das glaube ich sicher auch, klar.
Stalker, auch noch so ein Stichwort.
Man kann sich schnell das Leben schwer machen. Also man kann auch sagen, über alles Strahlung, ich gehe nicht mehr aus der Wohnung, ich benutze kein Handy mehr. Also das ist halt irgendwie auch Fortschritt. Street View ist doch super, ich finde das super cool, wenn ich mir da einfach mehr Straßen angucken kann. Und die Gefahr des Porno Bildes, um darauf zurückzukommen, also im Haus klebt es, dass dann auch einer sieht. Wenn man sich so ein Bild hinklebt, will man doch eigentlich aus, so wie man sieht. Die Gefahr würde ich dann in Kauf nehmen.
Also mal zusammengefasst, sagst du schon auch, man soll schon gucken, was man über sich ins Netz stellt?
Definitiv.
Aber du hast irgendwie keine Angst davor, mit den Daten, die du entschlossen hast, ins Netz zu stellen, ist es dann auch okay, dass die verarbeitet werden?
Exakt. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist halt so ein Selbstläufer, je öfter man drüber redet und so, desto panischer wird man und ist dann nicht mehr so rational in dem Gedanken, was ist tatsächlich die konkrete Gefahr? Oder ist es mehr so ein Reflex, oh Gott, Daten, Panik, gefährlich, sammeln und so weiter. Also das ist so ein Ding, wo ich einfach denke, da muss man immer mal sich selber nochmal erden und überlegen, was ist denn jetzt, wie gesagt, wirklich das Schlimmste, was da tatsächlich passieren kann?
Bis ein selber mal der Gmail-Account gehackt wird und in seinem Namen Spam, Viagra-Spam an alle seine Geschäftsfahler verschickt wird.
Das ist noch keinem, der dir anwesenden passiert.
Das kann es natürlich sein. Wenn einem wirklich mal so was passiert ist, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ganz anders drüber denken. Aber das kann ich mir ja dann Gedanken drüber machen. Aber da muss ich jetzt nicht vorher Panik schieben und mich dadurch selber erden.
So lange alles gut ist, erst mal weitermachen, ja?
Schönes Schlussstatement.
Ja, dank euch.
Tschüss. Finden wir denn vielleicht noch einen Anrufer, genau eben mit so einem Missbrauchsszenarien-Account gehackt und Schindluder mitbetrieben, Stalker, Ex-Freunde und so weiter. Also ich mein, das ist halt wahrscheinlich so das Realste, was so auch gar nicht so unhäufig passiert und das, ja.
Also ihr habt ja mal gehört, wenn ihr schon mal irgendwie gehackt worden seid oder euch die Identität geklaut wurde oder euch irgendjemand gestalkert mit Informationen aus dem Netz, dann...
Jetzt anrufen!
Der hat gar kein Problem, glaube ich, oder? Toni?
Du hast keine Probleme.
Nee, also ich habe mit dem Ganzen auch absolut gar kein Problem, weil ich bin ganz normaler Internetnutzer, habe ein Google-Handy und allen drum und dran und habe nie Probleme damit gehabt und finde es total Quatsch, jetzt hier dieses Street-View so da schlecht zu machen und einen...
Das ist ja nicht nur Street-Views, aber wenn du schon gesagt hast, du hast ein Google-Handy, synchronisierst du deine Kontakte mit Google? Na klar. Wurdest du, wie Hucke vorhin schon vorgeschlagen hat, die Kontakte auch ihm anvertrauen wollen, wenn er dir verspricht, dass er die Kontakte, dass er da gut drauf aufpasst und wenn du mal irgendwie eine Telefonnummer nachschlagen möchtest, die er dir nennt?
Nee, also ich gebe jetzt nicht irgendjemanden jetzt hier irgendwelche Kontakte, weil die sind natürlich für die privat, aber...
Ich habe auch eine Algebäe.
Letztendlich ist ja auch kein Unterschied zum Telefonbuch früher. Da stand ja auch für jede Adresse zu jeder Telefonnummer zu jedem Namen.
Ja gut, aber da stand eine Name und eine Telefonnummer drin und nicht die Person kennt dieses Set an 100 Leuten. So sind eben seine Kontakte.
Also wir kommen jetzt mal zu einer wirklich wichtigen Frage des Abends. Und die ist, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Huckel und Google? Und das klären wir nach den Nachrichten mit Vertrauen Verkehr.
Robbie Williams, Yandilay, Savian Aldo, Gossip und Rihanna live.
Kein Wunder, dass die Tickets für den Echo in Berlin innerhalb von 7 Minuten weg waren. Aber Fritz, wäre nicht Fritz, wenn wir nicht doch ordentlich Tickets für euch gebunkert hätten?
Jetzt präsentiert die Echo Verleihung 2010 in Berlin.
Mit Rihanna, Sadie Naidoo, Yandilay, Gossip und Robbie Williams.
Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Und wir sind nicht nur live mit dem Fritz Echo Radio dabei, sondern haben auch jede Menge aller allerletzte Tickets. Nur für euch und nur zu gewinnen.
Ab Montagmorgen.
Einfach gut Fritz hören.
Fritzie.
Der Echo 2010 in Berlin. Donnerstag 4. März. Live im ersten deutschen Fernsehen.
Und im letzten deutschen Radio.
Und das hört man.
Um kurz vor halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
In Brandenburg können Schüler aus sozial schwachen Familien in Zukunft kostenlos zur Schule und wieder nach Hause fahren. Der Landtag stimmte heute einen entsprechenden Antrag der Fraktionen von SPD und Linkspartei zu. Zur Begründung hieß es, Kinder aus Familien, die Sozialleistungen beziehen, müssten die gleichen schulischen Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten haben wie alle übrigen Kinder. Die FDP wollte, dass alle Schüler kostenlos fahren können. Das wurde aber abgelehnt. Der Führerschein mit 17 soll zur Regel werden. Bis zum Ende des Jahres soll das gesetzlich umgesetzt werden. Das kündigte Bundesverkehrsminister Ramsauer an. Er sagte, das begleitende Fahren bringe mehr Sicherheit für junge Fahranfänger. Als erstes Bundesland hatte im Jahr 2004 Niedersachsen den Führerschein mit 17 eingeführt. Dabei dürfen junge Fahranfänger, bis sie 18 sind, nur in Begleitung eines Erwachsenen ans Steuer. Für junge Berliner ist es heute offenbar schwieriger, einen Ausbildungsplatz oder einen Job zu finden als noch vor 20 oder 30 Jahren. Das kam bei einer Umfrage unter 1000 Berlinern raus. Die Mehrheit der Befragten ist der Meinung, dass sich die Politik noch zu wenig für die Schulabgänger einsetzt und dass die Berliner Unternehmen zu wenige Ausbildungsplätze anbieten. Laut der Umfrage sind vor allem gute Deutschkenntnisse wichtig, um bei der Jobsuche erfolgreich zu sein. In der zweiten Fußballbundesliga hat Union Berlin am Abend ein Auswärtsspiel bei Hansa Rostock gehabt. Das Spiel endete 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Neuropin und Angermünde haben wir 0 Grad. 1 Grad sind es in Potsdam, Frankfurt und Wittenberge, in Cottbus 2 und in Berlin zwischen 1 und 2 Grad. Nachts ist es wolkig, mit etwas Regen. Im Morgen gibt es vereinzelt noch Schnee. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus 2 und minus 1 Grad. Morgen ist auch wieder Tauwetter angesagt mit Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 11 Grad. Und ab und zu kann es etwas regnen oder Nieseregen. Davos geht euch eine gute Fahrt, es ist nämlich alles frei.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Heute Chaos Radio mit Huckel und Liebler vom Chaos Computer Club und mir, Markus Richter. Und es geht heute um... Diggins, was ist der heißt?
Google-Hupf.
Google-Hupf, genau. Und wir haben jetzt schon die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, ob Google vielleicht gefährlich ist, dass die ziemlich viele Daten um uns haben und ich würde jetzt die letzte halbe Stunde gerne auch noch mal ein bisschen dazu nutzen, um über die möglichen Alternativen zu reden und überhaupt darüber zu reden, ob es überhaupt Alternativen gibt oder ob man sich einfach nur heutzutage noch aussuchen kann, wo man jetzt seine Daten alle sammeln lässt.
Aber wenn ihr zum Beispiel gar keine Anrufe und so von Missbrauchsfällen berichtet und so weiter, dann ist ja auch vielleicht einfach alles gut.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Genau. Das hat mir vorhin schon gesagt. Also wenn ihr missbraucht worden seid durch euren Google oder was auch immer Account, dann jetzt anrufen. Jetzt haben wir den Sven dran, der meint, wir hätten was ganz Wichtiges vergessen.
Ja, und zwar schütten wir alle über Google Street View und genau wie wir damals schon geschützt haben über Google Maps und mit der Satelliten Ansicht, was ich auch noch gar nicht gehört habe, über Microsoft Bing die Maps, die wir dort anbieten, die sind ja teilweise auch noch ein bisschen umfangreicher als die ganzen Google Maps Geschichten.
Zeig dich mal fest, sitzt du gut? Da gab es neulich so eine Präsentation von Microsoft, dass sie an der Technologie arbeiten, die Livestreaming-Daten mit einbinden kann. Also da wurde eine Bilderkennung, eine Mustererkennung durchgeführt, kann man mit einer Kamera, einem Mobiltelefon zum Beispiel bestimmte Gegenfilme durch das GPS, wurde festgestellt, wo sich der Mensch ungefähr befindet und über die Ähnlichkeit zu bereits vorhandenen Bildern, die schon mal aufgezeichnet wurden, wird dann das jeweilige Video-Bild in das Bild, was man da schon gespeichert hat, eingeblendet. Du hast da so ein Live-Video-Fenster, was dir die Daten anzeigt, die eben gerade diese Kamera aufnimmt, in der passenden Umgebung. Also da ist quasi so ein Fenster in die Realität, was in Echtzeit aktualisiert wird. Gibt es auf ted.com, kann man sich mal angucken, wie so die Zukunfts-Terror-Vision aussieht, was so Daten von öffentlichen Plätzen aussehen.
Es geht ja an der Stelle dann auch weiter. Microsoft zeigt da jetzt gerade sozusagen in dieser Demo, wo es hingeht in den nächsten Evolutionenstufen. Dann haben wir auch alle im iPhoto oder im Picase so eine automatische Gesichtserkennung drin, um unsere Freunde gleich automatisch auf den Fotos zu sortieren. Auch total denkbar, dass das dann einfach auch direkt sozusagen im Streetview vorbei scrollen, ach guck mal, hier ist Tante Erna, mit integriert wird und so weiter. Also klar, das bleibt natürlich auch nicht stehen. Also der Ausblick nach vorne, also das war jetzt sozusagen bis hier in der Momentaufnahme und natürlich, das geht alles noch viel weiter.
Ich meine, wenn man sich, ich weiß ja nicht, den Film Google Epic 2015 kennt ja auf jeden Fall jeder von euch.
Okay, aber für alle, die es nicht kennen, was ist das?
Google Epic ist ein Film, der wurde gemacht 2004, wenn mich recht alles erinnert. Da ging es damals rum, da hatte Google gerade Keyhole gekauft, glaube ich, um die ganzen Bilder zu machen und da wurde so ein bisschen gesponnen, was passiert noch bis 2015 so ungefähr mit der ganzen Entwicklung Google und Co. Und wenn man sich den Film heute mal anschaut und berücksichtigt, dass der von 2004 ist, dann ist schon sehr erschreckend viel davon genau so umgesetzt worden. Also gerade wenn ich mir jetzt Google mit dem mit Latitude zum Beispiel angucke, da wurde damals auch gesponnen, man kann unterwegs seinen Podcast selber schicken, die Freunde sehen halt per GPS, wo man gerade ist und ist halt genauso eingebunden, also so wie Basket zum Beispiel von Google gestartet ist. Also genauso hat man das 2004 ungefähr vorhergesagt und da hat sich den Film das erste Mal 2006 oder so gesehen, da habe ich gesagt, naja, das ist ganz schön gruselig. Wenn man sowas aber zurückklicken sieht, also gibt es ja überall, Google auch bei YouTube zu finden, also Google Epic 2015 ist ein sehr interessantes Film. Also man hat so recht gesponnen, was passiert wenn und genau, wo es eigentlich auch passt zu kommen.
Und was ist deine Konsequenz daraus?
Meine Konsequenz ist sowieso, jeder sollte eigentlich aufpassen, was er selbst preisgibt. Also so wie der, ich weiß jetzt nicht wer hat das gesagt, wenn du nicht willst, dass etwas rauskommt, tu es nicht. Also ich würde auch sagen, wenn du nicht willst, dass etwas im Internet präsentiert wird, dann schickst du das gar nicht dahin. Wenn man sich teilweise Leute anschaut, was sie bei Facebook alles posten.
Aber da sind wir uns ja einig, da wird ja kaum noch eigentlich drüber diskutiert. Mit Tag gibt es auch da Leute, die sind anderer Meinung, aber es geht ja hier eher um die Dinge, die das Netz über dich weiß, einfach weil du da drin unterwegs bist.
Ja klar, man kann es dann irgendwann, also es wird mit der Zeit sicherlich immer schwerer selbst zu bestimmen, wie viele Daten man rausgibt. Also alleine schon, wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt eine alternative Suchmaschine haben will, die nicht die IP speichert oder jetzt halt nicht den Suchverlauf kontrolliert, für den normalen Nutzer halt relativ schwer, sag ich mal, an solchen Sachen ranzukommen. Klar, das wird halt immer schwieriger, darüber noch Herr über seine eigenen Daten zu werden. Aber das können wir glaube ich so richtig gar nicht gegen machen, gegen diese Entwicklung. Weil die Leute, die darüber schimpfen, andersrum, aber auch die sind, die das alles am meisten nutzen, weil sie dieses ganze Angebot, was es im Internet gibt. Und man sollte echt vielleicht so in der Schule, in den Schulen heute schon anfangen, so eine Art...
Medienkompetenz.
Ja, so Medienkompetenz zu schaffen, damit die Schüler echt, ich meine gerade die Schüler von heute, wenn man sich die anschaut an den Schulen, ins Film, so ein Handyvideo, laden das hoch und wissen eigentlich gar nicht, was sie damit tun. Also so wie jetzt die Google Chefs da verklagt wurden oder jetzt auch verurteilt wurden, wegen diesem einen Video, das hätten sich die, die das gefilmt haben, auch niemals ausgerechnet. Dass da irgendwelche Leute für verklagt werden, dass die ein Video hochladen, muss halt irgendjemanden da drangsalieren.
Also es ist halt irgendwie, es fehlt auf jeden Fall bei der jungen Generation, so scheint es zumindest, aber wie sehen Sie eben so das Bewusstsein, dass es eben nicht den digitalen Aktenvernichter gibt, so wie bei der Bundeswehr oder bei irgendwelchen Spendenaffären oder sonst was, wo man dann, ups, mir ist gerade so ein Aktenordner in den Aktenvernichter gefallen, können wir leider nichts mehr machen, sondern dass irgendwie das, was sie jetzt so mit 12, 13, 14 da ins Netz pumpen, einfach noch ihr ganzes Leben da drin stehen wird und auf ewig sozusagen verfügbar ist.
Du meinst also, dass sie Transparenz schaffen, eine Lösung für diverse politische Vorgänge, die eher im Dunkeln stattfinden, Google Documents werden?
Super. Also Sven, ich werde dich jetzt schonmal verabschieden, weil es ist ja quasi 20 Minuten vor 12 und die Leitungen sind noch voll.
Genau.
Ich habe schon einen wichtigen Punkt angesprochen, also es ist nicht nur Google, die damit kommen, sondern der Trend geht allgemein dazu, dass andere Firmen, also das generelle Firmen im Internet, die Verarbeitung der Daten anbieten, dass man seine Dokumente hochladen und bearbeiten kann, von überall aus das Konzept, was dahintersteckt ist, den Benutzern einfach Convenience anzubieten. Das ist einfach furchtbar praktisch, Dinge im Web zu haben, von überall auf seinen Account, auf einem Server, der bei einer Firma steht, zugreifen zu können und da an seine Dokumente zu können. Es gibt heutzutage immer mehr Firmen, die teilweise internste Dokumente in solchen Diensten nutzen, weil eben die Optionen...
Genau, ich habe hier mal unseren Geschäftsplan und irgendwie kannst du nochmal drüber gucken. Ich habe das immer gerade in Google Spreadsheets hochgeladen. Hier ist der URL.
Gab es eigentlich schon mal irgendwie, wo das rausgekommen ist? Also Gauss? Gibt es eigentlich Google Gauss tatsächlich?
Also es gibt bestimmt Blue Pass, also so aus Versehen mal ins falsche Chatfenster gepastet und so. Also das kann ja immer passieren.
Aber das kann ja quasi auch verschicken und dann falsche E-Mail-Adresse. Aber gab es tatsächlich, also gab es tatsächlich, ist auch eine Frage im Wiki zur Sendung, gab es tatsächlich schon mal eine richtige Katastrophe mit Google-Daten?
Ja, das wollen wir wissen.
Okay, anscheinend.
Also mir ist auf jeden Fall kein riesiger Fall bekannt. Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch in meiner Leitung?
Ja, hallo?
Du nutzt Google ja oder nein?
Ja.
Nämlich was?
Eigentlich nur die Suche über Google. Also Stichwörter oder ähnliche Sachen.
Warum nicht noch anderes Zeug?
Na, weil ich auch der Meinung bin, dass das alles zu undurchsichtig ist. Was mit meinen Daten passiert, wo die hingehen, wie die gespeichert werden.
Also das kann man selber persönlich nie nachvollziehen.
Aber warum hast du ein Problem damit?
Na, ähm, ja ein Problem damit. Also im Großen und Ganzen habe ich damit eigentlich kein Problem. Also so hat es Vorteile oder es hat auch Nachteile, wie schon gesagt wurde.
Alles hat so seine Vor-
Genau, erotische Bilder zum Beispiel, die man dann sehen könnte. Wenn ich so ein Bild raushänge, muss ich davon ausgehen, dass das Leute, die vorbeigehen, das sehen wird.
Das ist ganz klar.
Wie zum Beispiel habe ich eben gerade zu einem Kollegen schon gesagt, Weihnachten, ich hänge Weihnachtsbeleuchtung raus, damit es die ganze Welt sieht oder die Leute, die vorbeigehen und sich daran erfreuen. Und wenn jetzt Google Feedview zum Beispiel, da hat zu der Zeit gerade mein Haus so viel Normat, freue ich mich natürlich übelst darüber. Aber andererseits kann man das auch negativ nutzen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, sag ich mal, jetzt Verbrecher oder so was, oder Diebe oder so.
Ja gut, aber das ist, wie sie sagen, finde ich auch eins der eher schwammigeren Argumente, weil wenn ich irgendwo einbreche mit Verlaub, dann fahre ich hin und mache Hochglanzaufnahmen, damit ich genau weiß, welche Türschlösser die haben und so.
Ja, richtig, richtig, aber da steckt ja dann wieder Arbeit hinter. Also ich muss mich ins Auto setzen, muss da und da hinfahren, muss irgendwelche Akquise betreiben und so, setze ich mich in Sicherheit an Rechner.
Heißt das, dass du am liebsten hättest, dass Google möglichst gar nicht über uns speichert?
Naja, oder wie halt schon meine Vorredner gesagt haben, dass sie wenigstens nachfragen. Und wenn es denen dann halt zu teuer ist, naja, dann wird sie gut haltig machen.
Alles klar, Martin sagt, Google soll nur die Sachen speichern, die wirklich frei geben werden. Das finde ich ja auch so ein Ärgerlich, so ein Ärgernis bei jedem neuen Dienst, den Google eigentlich macht. Sagen, dass sie immer dieses, es gibt dieses Opt-in und Opt-out und eigentlich schalten sie immer erstmal alles frei. Könntet ihr nicht mal was machen?
Muss man sich aber auch vor Augen führen. Google führt zu Produkten ja nicht für 1, 2, 3 User ein, sondern die machen das gleich für Millionen von Nutzern. Das ist ein Massenbetrieb und viele Leute lassen das auf Standardeinstellungen. Das ist für Google ganz einfach am praktischsten und augenscheinlich für die Nutzer, wenn Google damit nichts Böses macht, auch bietet dem Nutzer den meisten Mehrwert, wenn die Daten verarbeitet werden können.
Das heißt im Prinzip, also von manchen Leuten her, dass die Daten nicht mehr verarbeitet werden können, ist einfach doch eine gute Sache. Jenny zum Beispiel, die muss mit Google arbeiten.
Hallo. Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Wieso das?
Ja, ich bin da, hallo.
Wieso musst du mit Google arbeiten?
Weil ich AdWords betreue. Das sind diese kleinen Anzeigen, die in der Google-Suche ganz oben und rechts stehen.
Für eine Firma, für mehrere Firmen?
Für mittlerweile nur noch eine Firma.
Weil sich das nicht lohnt oder?
Es lohnt sehr. Es lohnt, dass ich es nur noch für eine Firma tun muss.
Verstehe. Und nutzt du Google auch noch privat?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dadurch bin ich total Google-affin. Ich habe eine Google-Mail-Adresse. Ich benutze alle möglichen Oberflächen, die man sich vorstellen kann. Aber Dokumente teile ich noch nicht.
Wenn du mit den AdWords arbeitest, erfährt man da irgendetwas? Oder was lernst du da? Oder nach welchen Kriterien arbeitest du da mit den AdWords?
Ich habe eine Art Segmente zur Verfügung, wo ich Werbung schalten kann. Ich hätte zu den Zielworten, die dort eingetippt werden, vom Kunden oder vom Suchenden. Dazu passt es ja. Aber es geht ja noch viel weiter, dass Webseiten angemeldet sind bei Google, die dann auch Banner ausliefern und auch Texten zeigen. Das wird zu bestimmten Schlagworten ausgeliefert, die der Kunde hinterlässt und worum sich die Webseite handelt. Viel wird auch in Foren ausgeliefert. Als Marketer ist das natürlich total spannend.
Aber die Dinge, die du hast zu sagen, ist es einfach nur Werbestatistik im Sinne von, du weißt welche AdWords erfolge sind? Oder glaubst du, dass man, wenn man weiß, nach welchen Worten jemand sucht, dass man auch sagen kann, was für eine Person das ist?
Nein, das kann man natürlich nicht. Also ich kann nicht auf die IP-Adresse runterbrechen.
Das ist schon klar, aber vom Personenprofil, also du machst ja schon wahrscheinlich Gedanken drum, wer was verkunden möchte, meinen Kunden an...
Genau, also ich kann das Alter, Geschlecht und so weiter. Solche Sachen sind durchaus möglich.
Wie funktioniert das?
Das bietet sozusagen diese AdWords-Oberfläche im Bereich Content.
Ich möchte gar nicht, dass diese Werbung von 14-jährigen männlichen Jugendlichen gesehen wird.
Genau. Also ich möchte, dass wenn... Sofern Google darauf Zugriff hat, ja wir haben ja nicht auf allen Webseiten diesen Zugriff auf die Daten, aber dort wo sie es haben, ja.
Weißt du, wo man das herkriegt? Also wo Google die Daten herkriegt?
Ähm, ja durch die Profile, die hinterlegt sind. Also ich nehme mal irgendein Forum, das ist nur richtig groß, und da sind irgendwelche Leute angemeldet mit ihrem Namen, mit ihrem Geburtsdatum, mit dem Ort, wo sie leben. Das ist ja auch eine ganz interessante Sache, dass ich Werbung treiben kann, dass ich sagen kann, ich möchte genau jemanden in Berlin Mitte erreichen, der dann auch noch am besten männlich ist. Ich meine, das engt natürlich als Marketingtreibender das total ein, aber natürlich total spannend das zu tun. Das ist einfach nur eine Schablone, die ich ausfülle.
Das ist aber schon ein gutes Beispiel, an dem man sehen kann, dass es nicht unbedingt die ganz persönlichen Schreckensszenarien sind, von wegen jemand kann rausfinden, was ich ganz persönlich gemacht habe, sondern auch ganz banal eben, ja.
Dass ich halt etwas zugeschnittenes bekomme, also viele, ich bin ja selber ganz oft erschrocken, wenn ich mein E-Mail-Postfach aufmache und vorher mit meiner Schwester über die Wohnungsgestaltung gesprochen habe, per E-Mail, welche Wandfarbe sie benutzt und bald in einer Stunde später bekomme ich die perfekt passenden Adwords drumherum. Also selbst mich erschreckt das noch, aber da sieht man auch, wie gut das System funktioniert.
Aber das, sagen, führt nicht dazu, dass du dein Verhalten änderst?
Nein.
Loggst du dich bei Google aus, bevor du suchst?
Ähm, nein.
Nein oder nicht immer?
Also ich filogentiere wirklich meine Kugels selbstverständlich, also das ist irgendwie so Berufskrankheit wahrscheinlich.
Warum das?
Weil man dann glaubt, dass man eben so ein bisschen entkommt.
Bleibst du bei Google weiterhin eingeduckt?
Nein, bestimmt auch nicht immer, aber doch über eine Tagesnutzung schon, ja.
Hat sich dein Verhältnis zu Kugels und diesem Einloggen und Ausloggen verändert durch deine Arbeit?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich hatte vorher gar kein Bewusstsein, also wirklich gar nicht und bin Schritt für Schritt, also eigentlich eher noch so über andere Bereiche dazu gekommen, wie viel man tatsächlich ablegen kann, also wie so ein Protokoll tatsächlich aussieht. Und ich fand das unglaublich. Ich bin überhaupt nicht auf über die technische Schiene daran gekommen, sondern halt von dieser Marketing Schiene. Und klar, das ist natürlich ein Traum, irgendwie eine C-Gruppe so einengen zu können, aber selber zu C-Gruppen zu gehören, das ist natürlich auch ein komisches Gefühl gewesen. Aber gerade was so andere Social-Geschichten auch angeht und auch Google Mail mit allem drum und dran, da ist der Spaßfaktor denn oft wichtiger als die Sicherheit. Das ist ganz verblüffend.
Also beobachtest du bei anderen Leuten?
Bei mir selber.
Bei dir selber?
Ja, obwohl mir das relativ bewusst ist, geh ich da doch sehr offen mit um.
Ist das sozusagen auch so eine Art, dass du quasi gute Vorsätze hast, die du aber nicht einhältst?
Ja, so ungefähr, kann man schon sagen. Ich sehe Google halt nicht als große Bedrohung. Ich habe einfach aufgehört, diese Diskussion weiter zu führen. Aber es ist für mich auch eine endlose Diskussion. Wir hatten ja jetzt auch schon in der Sendung verschiedene Beispiele dafür, dass man sich auch wirklich kaputt machen kann. Weil ich finde es jetzt wie gesagt, ich wollte einfach nur mal diese Sichtweise reinbringen, weil sich ja viele auch immer fragen, warum machen die das? Die machen Kohle damit, das ist ganz eindeutig. Umso besser die Anzeigen in einem bestimmten Werbeumfeld passen, umso mehr klicken die Leute drauf, umso mehr verdienen Google.
Das glaube ich genau, dass Spagat den Googler betreiben muss. Auf der einen Seite die Werbegründen zufriedenstellen, aber auf der anderen Seite über die Nutzer nur so viele Daten rausgeben, wie sie müssen, und auf dem Rest der Daten sitzen bleiben und gucken, dass nichts passiert und keine negative PR kommt.
Ja, und das ist ja auch, wenn man an die Suchanfragen selber, also auf der Suchschule, wo man sozusagen denkt, dann sieht man ja auch, also es würde alles nicht funktionieren, wenn die nicht Daten speichern würden, dann könnten sie das System nicht verbessern und das ernährt sich ja davon, dass Leute einen bestimmten Weg immer und immer wieder gehen. Also das ist einfach, dieser Algorithmus beinhaltet ja genau das. Das bedingt sich gegenseitig. Es gibt, weil wir jetzt auch irgendwie bei dem Thema waren, was gibt es für Alternativlösungen? Keine Ahnung.
Mir stellt sich gerade noch eine Frage, du arbeitest ja selber damit und findest es geil, weil du halt deine Werbung so einschränken kannst, und dass du genau schalten kannst. Andererseits ist dir dabei ein bisschen komisch. Würdest du, wenn sozusagen oder andersrum, wie viel wäre es dir wert, in Geld, in Euro ausgedrückt, sozusagen, dass du genau dieselbe Komfort, also Bequemlichkeit haben kannst, aber dir wird garantiert, dass deine Daten dann nicht mehr weiterverarbeitet werden?
Würde ich eh keinem glauben.
Richtiger Antwort, ja.
Also das ist einfach zu verführerisch, diese Daten zu verwenden. Wie gesagt, es ist ja eigentlich nur eine Maschine, in die ich etwas eingebe und ich bekomme etwas wieder. Und wie soll jemand meine Daten nicht versenden? Wie soll der etwas optimieren können? Woran macht er das fest? Also ich würde es ihm nicht glauben.
Okay, und sozusagen selbst gesetzt den Fall, es gäbe jetzt sozusagen so eine magische Black Box, wo das irgendwie funktionieren würde, mich würde halt diese Summe interessieren, ob es für dich tatsächlich so eine Art Wert hat, oder ob du schon gesagt hast, okay, das ist halt einfach so.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also da bin ich wahrscheinlich es genau so, dass ich irgendwie gemerkt habe jetzt in der ganzen Diskussion, ich bin über den Berg. Ich hab mich ewig, ich find's ganz lustig, eine Freundin von mir hat jetzt bei Facebook irgendwie gepostet, ich bin ein Medien-Dozialist oder so. Und dann gab's halt ein schönes Comic, wie jemand sagt, von wegen Payday-Karte oder so, was schau ich nicht. Und in der nächsten Szene sitzt er halt vor Facebook oder irgendeinem Twitter-Ding und schreibt, dass er irgendwas ganz Intimes tut. Und ich hab mich extrem erwischt gefühlt.
Gibt's irgendwelche Daten, die du...
Also ich nutze keine Payday-Karten, ich find das grauenvoll. Ich sag ständig zu irgendwelchen Frauen an den Kassen, ich möchte kein lesender Kunde sein. Und arbeite aber auf einem ganz anderen Gebiet total ähnlich.
Gibt's irgendwelche Daten, die du Google nicht anvertrauen würdest?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Du sollst jetzt nicht die Daten ja ausbreiten, aber unter welche Kategorie fallen die?
Privat ist das Privatleben. Also meine Beziehung, mein Kind, mein...
Aber das bedeutet eigentlich, in der Mail, die du über Google verschickst, dürftest du dann nicht über dein Kind schreiben?
Google mich nach Kinderspielzeugen suchen, das fand ich auch ziemlich scary. Sie haben beim Super Bowl, was so ziemlich die teuerste Werbezeit in den USA ist, hat Google eine Werbung gehabt mit einer Sucheingabe-Box, wo jemand sich erst erkundigt hat nach ja, na, how to impress a French woman job in Paris and how to build a crib. Das fand ich ziemlich scary.
Weil?
Weil das einem doch vor Augen führt, dass jede Frage an Google eine Antwort für Google ist. Wenn ich Google nach was frage, dann ist das, sagt man damit, ich habe Interesse an einer bestimmten Sache. Ich habe eine bestimmte Fragestellung, die mich bewegt. Da kann man Rückschlüsse ziehen.
Und das glaube ich genau.
Also klar, wenn jemand sich richtig Mühe geben würde, könnte er über mich auch sonst was rausfinden. Also was ich in den letzten Jahren zusammen gegoogelt habe, ist wahrscheinlich auch unglaublich. Und ich bin total dankbar aber für diesen Informationszugang. Also ich meine, viele kennen ja auch gar nicht die ganzen Möglichkeiten von Google. Ich bin nur ein ganz großer Fan geworden über die Zeit. Also schon dieses Cola oder Book Search oder weiss ich irgendwas.
Also zusammengefasst kann man sagen, Jenny findet Google total toll, aber es ist doch irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl, genau zu wissen.
Also es ist natürlich bedrückend und in solchen Diskussionen kommt einem auch immer wieder seltsam vor, sicherlich. Und ich bin auch durchaus umgeben von Menschen, die es sehr, sehr kritisch sehen. Also die Diskussion ist nicht alltäglich, aber fast.
Gut, und bei dir wird sich auf jeden Fall auch nichts ändern.
Vielleicht habe ich mal ein brutales Erlebnis, keine Ahnung, hoffentlich nicht.
Da sind wir immer noch auf der Suche. Alles klar, falls sich da noch jemand meldet, dann anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Vielen Dank Jenny. So jetzt müssen wir uns aber langsam schon richtig beeilen.
Moment, wir singen ja jetzt noch schwule Mädchen in der Zugabe und so. Aber ich fand das jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mal so gegen Ende genau auf den Punkt gebracht. Diese Ambivalenz zwischen toll, nützlich und will ich haben und eben genau diesem mulmigen Gefühl. Das ist einfach gerade noch mal schön auf den Punkt gebracht. Und das mit den Adwords, dass es diese Schablone da gibt, war mir auch gar nicht so bewusst.
Vor allem auch diese Daten, dass man wirklich sagen kann, ich möchte Personen in einer Zielgruppe von bis aus.
Ja, ich meine, das gab es früher auch schon von Dienstleistern, aber jetzt ist es halt einfach im Web und für jeden halt zugänglich.
Bei Facebook geht das auch. Da kann man auch klicken sozusagen. Ich möchte gerne Werbung machen für Leute zwischen die aus Berlin kommen.
Spezifisch auf Facebook bei Google ist das Besondere, dass diese Werbung eben nicht nur auf einer Seite ist. Und dass über diese AdSense Geschichte das auf...
Du gehst halt auf Google Maps, guckst jetzt eine Straße nach und plopp, sind in der Cyber gleich mal die entsprechenden Geschäfte wurde da einer.
Das gehört so. Jetzt haben wir noch einen. Weil wir vorhin auch über Streetview geredet hatten. Du wärst enttäuscht, lese ich hier, wenn ein Haus nicht drin wäre.
Ja. Ich war für Quatschhalter. Ich halte es für übertrieben, diese Geschichte mit dem das Recht am eigenen Bild auf das Recht am eigenen Haus auszudehnen. Ich halte es einfach für Blödsinn. Es wird heutzutage, wenn man das konsequent zu Ende denkt, wird es fast völlig unmöglich gemacht, irgendwo in der Öffentlichkeit noch irgendein Foto zu machen. Und das sei es kommerziell zu verwenden oder auch privat zu verwenden. Weil was ist denn private Verwendung, wenn ich sie veröffentliche? Ich lege das auf irgendeinen Webstore ab und letzten Endes ist es dann ja doch wieder irgendwo wahrscheinlich auf dem Dienst von einer kommerziellen Firma, die letztes Jahr ist damit Geld verdient. Also im Prinzip müsste ich es komplett verbieten.
Also du meinst irgendwie, das ist sowieso jetzt soweit und wir stellen einfach unsere Daten auch ins Netz. Dafür erstmal vielen Dank. Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen beeilen, weil wir haben noch drei Leute, aber fast nicht mehr so viel Zeit dafür.
Christopher, wie siehst du das?
Ich sehe es so entweder ganz oder gar nicht.
Heißt?
Entweder ich will das Internet nutzen und muss damit klarkommen, dass irgendwo immer was gespeichert wird. Ob ich jetzt Google nicht nutze oder es nutze.
Wo immer Sachen gelockt und mitgeschrieben werden.
Ich sag mal so, wenn es jetzt eine Firma macht oder ganz viele, wenn ich jetzt das Ganze aussplitte, email, dann mein Telefon, dann habe ich meinen Internetzugang da noch. Man muss einfach irgendwo auch ein bisschen Vertrauen haben und wie ja auch schon gesagt wurde, euch ist ja auch keine Panne bei Google bekannt.
Aber einer Bank...
Willst du dein Telefonbuch einfach vertrauen?
Ich sag mal so, ja, es ist ja dann nur eine einzige Person und nicht erstmal so eine riesengroße Community, die da drauf zugrafen könnte oder die... Ich denk mal, Google könnte das dann besser vermarkten als er.
Ich bin sehr vertrauenswürdig.
Ja, ich meine, gut, der Hintertun, den du da so durchblicken lässt, ist natürlich dann eher der da nicht so dann auf Vertrauen steht.
Nein, ich bin da total vertrauenswürdig, auf jeden Fall.
Nein, also ehrlich.
Ich würde auch nur RGB...
Was mir jetzt noch nicht rauskommt, würdest du es bevorzugen, wenn verschiedene Leute deine Daten sammeln, was ja sowieso passiert, wie du sagst, oder ist es auch okay, wenn es eine einzelne große Firma macht?
Es ist in gewisser Weise egal, ja.
Okay, behältst du dich dann sozusagen, also dir ist das klar, das gehört dazu, hältst du dich in irgendeiner Art und Weise zurück, oder ist es einfach so, dass du für dich entschieden hast, okay, meine Daten werden jetzt gesammelt, ist mir egal?
Nee, also man hält sich natürlich jetzt schon zurück, indem man sagt, nur die Sachen, die man auch nach außen geben will, wie jetzt zum Beispiel vielleicht den Vornamen, oder wie hab ich ja jetzt auch preisgegeben zum Beispiel, und dass man halt sagt, jetzt nicht irgendwie sein Tagebuch, so was dann halt.
Aber das heißt auch so sagen, du dürftest nicht mehr nach Dingen in der Suchmaschine suchen, die privat sind.
Ja gut, was ist denn wieder privat? Und wenn ich jetzt nach meinem Tagebuch google, wenn ich mir Sachen kaufe zum Beispiel, wenn ich da nach google, ob das jetzt privat ist, es ist natürlich ein Interesse, die dann von Google vielleicht wieder zu Geld gemacht wird. Und ich denke, wenn ich jetzt wirklich was auf dem Kerbholz hab und dann Vaterstaat sagt, wir haben einen Beschluss, gibt uns jetzt mal das Profil, das Genaue. Ich finde, dass dann was auch schon gesagt wurde, man darf sich da nicht allzu hysterisch machen. Ich hätte dann eher Angst, dass dann irgendwann mal eine Panne kommt. Und dann schon fertige Profile dann quasi einem zur Verfügung stehen.
Aber das passiert ja, weil, wie du sagst, Daten werden sowieso gesammelt. Christopher, vielen Dank. Jetzt haben wir noch schnell den Tobias.
Ja, hi.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ach, ganz schnell.
Ja, so ganz schnell, wenn das überhaupt möglich ist. Geht eigentlich so ein bisschen um etwas der neueren Entwicklung von Google, nämlich Google Wave, was quasi so noch gar nicht erwähnt wurde. Ja, ich würd mal erst mal sagen, so Ersteindruck, so ein bisschen Suspect, relativ komisch. Also es geht ja quasi um das kollaborative Arbeiten an Dokumenten, an Projekten und an Präsentationen etc. Nur, ja, so wo es denn...
Okay, warte mal, es ist zwei vor zwölf ganz konkrete Frage. Was ist deine Frage oder dein Standpunkt?
Es ist ja nur wirklich sehr suspicious, dass Google, also ich hab direkt so immer das Gefühl gehabt, egal was ich da direkt schreibe, Google lief mit und wunderbar, egal was jetzt passiert, Google weiß es. Egal was für ein Projekt ich jetzt gerade mit irgendwelchen Bekannten zusammenschricke, Google könnte es verwenden, benutzen, die Ideen klauen.
Die spannende Frage ist, hält dich das irgendwie davon ab, Google zu benutzen?
Google Wave definitiv.
Was benutzt du stattdessen?
Google Suche, natürlich.
Was benutzt du statt Google Wave oder machst du keine online Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Leuten?
Das ist eben das Problem. Man muss eben Projekte halbwegs fertig machen und dann per Docfile oder sonstiges halt eben rübersenden. Also die Idee an sich finde ich mehr als nur genial, dass man eben direkt in der Zusammenarbeit in einem Text arbeiten kann, direkt sehen kann, was für Veränderungen gemacht wurden und die idealerweise auch editieren kann. Nur die Gesamtlösung, dass ein großer Konzern eben darüber steht und du nicht weißt, wo jetzt deine Daten überhaupt landen oder wie sie überhaupt gesichert werden können, das ist so ein großer Knackpunkt, der mich dann halt doch so ein bisschen davon abhält, Google Wave als effektive, firmeffiziente Lösung für Projektarbeiten zu benutzen.
Kann man also subsumieren unter Google oder Allgemeinen, oder gibt es in Zukunft Dienste, die einem das Leben leichter machen und man muss dafür eben eine Handvoll Daten hergeben, um diese Dienste zu bekommen? Wo man dann für sich persönlich die Entscheidung trifft, was für Daten bin ich da bereit reinzugeben, wo suche ich mir meine Alternativen, um noch einen kleinen Ausblick in die Zukunft zu werfen. Google ist in den USA gerade dabei, zum Internet Service Provider zu werden. Dazu muss man sagen, dass Google für Bandbreite momentan nicht wirklich was zahlen muss, weil jeder mit Google Daten austauschen möchte. Da geht die Zukunft hin, Google bietet heute schon einen offenen DNS-Service an. Also es bleibt weiter spannend. Die Daten werden mehr die Möglichkeiten, mit diesen Daten umzugehen werden mehr. Das muss, glaube ich, jeder für sich selbst die Lösung finden.
Und die Informationen wollen frei sein.
Das sollte einfach nochmal gesagt werden, habe ich Eindruck.
Also, Daten sind wie Wasser. Das kannst du halt nicht zusammenhalten. Und das fließt schon immer irgendwo der Gravitation nach.
Jetzt wird es gerade ganz schön leter, Jungs.
Nein, das ist total sozusagen die Essenz des Ganzen.
Was für mich die Essenz des Ganzen ist, dass sich ziemlich viele Leute so ein bisschen unwohl damit fühlen. Und denken, naja, irgendwie ist es schon komisch. Aber andererseits, wir benutzen es halt auch einfach, weil es so geil, schön funktioniert. Was daraus geworden ist, das können wir dann vielleicht einfach in einem Jahr besprechen.
Vor allen Dingen, aber was mich jetzt nochmal als Schlusspunkt echt fasziniert, es hat jetzt echt keine angerufen, der irgendwie eine negative Erfahrung damit gemacht hat. Also sie haben ihren Job halt auch echt verdammt gut gemacht, scheinbar. Also wenn wirklich niemand, der da jetzt irgendwie sich äußert, irgendeinen schlechten Clip mit Google gehabt hat. Also das ist auf jeden Fall auch sehr beeindruckend. Und für mich fast noch ein Grund mehr, das irgendwie mit einem mulmigen Gefühl zu beobachten.
Da kuckelt er heute beim Chaosradio dabei war. Auch Nibbler war dabei. Wir haben über Google gesprochen. Im Podcast gibt es wahrscheinlich ziemlich schnell in einschlägigen Quellen fritz.de oder chaosradio.de. Könnt ihr einfach so klicken. Jetzt kommt gleich Tobias Koch mit dem Night Flight. Wir sind raus und sagen...
Schwule Mädchen.
Wollte ich eigentlich nicht sagen. Ich wollte eigentlich den schönen Satz sagen, macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.